one of the most notable and exciting
things about final fantasy 7 remake was
the way it updated the original game's
combat system merging the feeling of
menu-based commands and action game
controls stranger of paradise final
fantasy origins does something similar
with a take on the job system that's a
big part of final fantasy history the
ability to switch between combat roles
on the fly allows for a whole lot of
interesting versatility adding tactical
considerations to protagonist jack's
angry shouting slashing and headbutting
during combat we recently got a chance
to play the second playable demo of
stranger of paradise ahead of its
release like the first demo it includes
the chaos shrine level that ends with
players taking on chaos also known as
garland but it also includes another
section that gives a sense of final
fantasy origins take on the series and
how expansive the job system really is
if you want to see more coverage of
stranger of paradise from gamespot make
sure to hit the like and subscribe
buttons below
the new demo for stranger of paradise
sends you back to the chaos shrine the
scene of the original playstation 5 demo
for the game but this time it adds some
new context that demo ended with you
taking on a night the protagonist
characters called garland who they also
think is some kind of evil entity known
as chaos and they really want to kill
chaos in the second demo defeating chaos
triggers a new cutscene that carries the
story a little further forward and
introduces a new character to your party
it turns out that the chaos advent you
had fought wasn't garland or a monster
it was another hero named neon it's uh
convoluted but it turns out that neon is
the fourth prophecied warrior of light
and joins up with the protagonist jack
and his pals to try to kill the real
chaos who neon doesn't really think
exists the demo then took us to a second
level the referent wetlands though we
didn't get much of a story prompt for
this level it seems like it's the first
stop on the party's trip to find a final
fantasy brand crystal that jack and co
need for their crusade against chaos the
interesting thing about referent
wetlands is that as you work your way
through it you'll use special
interactable nodes to change the weather
in the environment you could alternate
the environment between sunny and rainy
with some areas flooding in the rain and
barring your passage and other paths
closing off in the sun changing the
weather to alter the environment had a
more interesting effect though it
changes how some enemies fight you
several of the creatures we encountered
through the course of the wetlands have
electricity based attacks facing them in
the rain created big puddles where their
attacks were more effective but if you
had the forethought to find a node and
change the weather to sunny before a
fight you could take those abilities off
the table before the encounter even
started the main focus of our look at
the demo though was the job system
square enix gave us a chance to play the
referent wetlands mission with all jobs
unlocked and leveled up allowing us to
see how they all work in action a few of
the jobs appeared in the original demo
like swordsman pugilist mage and lancer
in the new demo we saw the addition of
neon as a sword fighter who carries both
a sword and a shield and more advanced
jobs like warrior knight thief and the
classic black white and red mages like
in final fantasy 1 and other ff games
once you advance a given job you can
unlock more varied in-depth versions of
that job you're free to swap jobs
whenever you want and from what we
played it seems like a good idea the
first demo showed off how tough combat
can be in stranger of paradise it takes
a lot of inspiration from other team
ninja games like neo this demo was big
on showing off how the jobs are
effective in different situations you
can equip two jobs to protagonist jack
at a time which you're able to then swap
between on the fly with a single button
press we found that to be great for
combining a melee class and a
spellcaster class which was essential in
the wetlands in addition to various
hungry beasts and electrically charged
reptiles hanging around there were also
elemental creatures that use spells like
fire and blizzard on our group having
the ability to swap to a black mage job
to hit fire elementals with water spells
made taking them down a lot easier but
even if you're not wielding magic you
can use jack's soul shield ability to
absorb a lot of different kinds of
attacks from enemies like their spells
and throw them back at them wielding
different abilities and using them in
different ways showed stranger of
paradise at its best you get a lot of
options for how to fight enemies which
class you pick allows you to focus on
different kinds of attacks and damage
types for instance the sword fighter is
big on direct damage to hp but doesn't
do much to stagger enemies while the
swordsman and the warrior are more about
driving up that stagger meter on foes to
get a finisher off on them but aren't
great at dealing direct damage hot
swapping between jobs means you could
wail on one creature dodge away for a
second then pull out something like your
white mage abilities and cast regen and
haste on your team before going back
into the fray the opportunities for
coming up with your own strategies and
synergies were particularly prevalent in
the referendum wetlands boss fight where
we fought a big metallic orb filled with
elemental energy the orb would
constantly spit out one of two different
elemental bosses a fire-based one and a
water-based one adjusting your strategy
for different situations for blasting
the elementals with different spells or
cutting in close to deal some melee
damage was key because if you let the
orb get the upper hand it might even
spawn both elementals at once with
jack's soul shield ability however it
was possible to block and capture one
elemental's abilities to use against the
other one stranger of paradise also
rewards you for building job affinity
with your characters certain weapons and
armor increase your job affinity as does
spending experience points to level up
that job the more affinity with the job
you have the more bonuses you accrue
allowing you to mix the upshots of one
job with the fighting style of another
you might get stat bonuses like an
agility boost from raising your affinity
as a lancer but higher affinities can
unlock actual job abilities to use even
if you don't have that job equipped we
also saw hybrid jobs like the red mage
which combines some of the black mage's
spell casting abilities with some of the
white mage's healing abilities you can
unlock those jobs as you climb other job
trees it's an expansive system that
gives you a whole lot of different
combat abilities combos and options for
how you want to deal with foes in fact
you might be a little too spoiled for
choice in stranger of paradise the job
system is extremely expansive almost to
the point of being overwhelming swapping
to a new job lets you set combos and
battle abilities and coupled with your
standard melee and spell casting
abilities your dodge your block your
parry mechanics your finishers and your
special lightbringer fighter mode i
straight up forgot about a lot of the
things i could be doing in a fight
executing your special job abilities
usually requires remembering relatively
simple button combos but in the heat of
battle you can never just stop and think
about what you want to do this also made
playing as a mage kind of annoying your
spell casting interface is a radial menu
you adjust with the thumb sticks while
you're charging a spell you have to pay
attention to spell selection spell
charging and spell targeting all at once
there's also stranger of paradise's big
emphasis on loot an rpg staple that
feels like it's been turned up very high
to some degree stranger of paradise is
an action take on final fantasy tropes
the mission screen for referent wetlands
shows the rewards you'll earn for
completing it which suggests you can
replay missions over and over to grind
better gear and increase your stats the
only trouble is you get a ton of loot
all the time i found myself stopping
every few steps to rearrange my gear as
i leveled up that said the gear system
like the job system seems cool and
expansive you're not just thinking about
what gear is giving your character the
best stats but what bonuses you get from
that gear in terms of job affinity
defensive perks and the like there's a
huge amount of customization on hand and
from the looks of things you can return
to levels and grind out better gear over
and over to make yourself an even more
powerful fighter the hints we've gotten
at stranger of paradise's story the
details of which have been minimal so
far are also pretty interesting neon's
introduction as a character who tried to
become chaos just so someone like jack
would have a chaos to kill is a really
weird and fascinating twist on the usual
final fantasy premise it sounds like
we're going to be fundamentally
questioning the idea of warriors of
light and fighting a big bad boss at the
end of a game it also seems like there
might be more than one set of heroes
since neon had a group of her own and we
might see some fundamental questioning
of the prophecies driving these heroes
on their quests my impression from the
second demo of stranger of paradise is
that its combat and systems are fun to
play with and interestingly responsive
building a uniquely final fantasy take
on some of the things we've seen from
other big action games such as neo but
there's also a lot to parse here and can
get confusing that said this spin on
final fantasy mechanics and combats is a
fascinating one and i enjoyed pummeling
my way through various enemies and tough
bosses it's a final fantasy game where
it feels like your strategic choices are
just as important as your quick reflexes
in combat and while everything you know
about final fantasy makes stranger
paradise feel familiar there's a lot
more going on under the surface of what
we've seen so far
[Music]
you